Cut.
[Inaudible].
The creepy basement is one of the most well-established tropes in the horror
genre.
And it makes sense that scary movies use basements to frighten the audience
they're confined dark and only have one exit for escape.
We know the threat of basements all too well, which explains why,
even just talking about one can feel ominous.
Hey, people have basements in California.
The fact that basements are underground adds to their creepiness.
There's something scary about the unknown depths of underground spaces in
general,
which might explain why nearly every ancient culture has some belief in an
underworld, a supernatural world of the dead that's below ground.
And those stories may seem like old tales that we don't believe in anymore,
but their influence still shows up in modern filmmaking, Clarice Starling,
entering a serial killer's dark basement to rescue a young girl in the silence
of the lambs.
It sounds a lot like the Greek story of the prophet Orpheus entering the
treacherous underworlds to rescue your a dicey, but in our storytelling,
the use of underground spaces goes even deeper than that.
When explored the underground actually has a vast collection of symbolic
meanings that you may not have even noticed.
So what are the potential meanings of the underground and how do filmmakers use
them to tell their stories? It's time to explore what lies beneath.
Got you. I'm not going down there. Okay. Okay. I'll go.
For many characters.
The underground represents what they're afraid of in home alone.
Kevin has that classic fear of the basement.
I've always been afraid of. [inaudible] stark, weird stuff down there,
and it smells.
In the film.
His fear of the basement symbolizes his inability to take care of himself after
his family abandoned him. But once he faces this fear
It shows that his character has grown the confidence to live on his own
characters. Often confront trauma while underground in the silence of the lambs.
Clarice talks about failing to save a screaming lamb as a child.
At the end of the film, instead of saving a literal lamb,
she has to save a symbolic lamb.
A helpless girl held captive by Buffalo bill for Clarice Bill's underground
layer represents her lifelong struggle to silence the lamps that have been
tormenting her. So when a character enters the underground,
they are in a way confronting repressed memories hidden away in their own mind.
The perfect example of the underground representing an individual's own mind,
it's the character Pennywise from it.
Not only does this evil clown live below ground,
but it also morphs into each character's greatest fear.
It's a literal manifestation of their deepest trauma. And in the case of bill,
his trauma comes from never coming to terms with the death of his brother in all
of these films, the underground acts as a space that holds the deepest,
most traumatic thoughts in a character's mind in the early 20th century,
psychoanalyst Sigmund Freud,
who developed a theory that call it this space in our minds, the it,
he describes the it as a dark inaccessible part of our personality that stores
are repressed fears, which sounds a lot like the basements in home alone.
And the silence of the lambs for its theory had a massive cultural impact.
It completely changed how people thought about their minds and that new thinking
made its way into filmmaking.
Even though much of Freud's work has become outdated.
His theories continued to influence how we think about the mind today in classic
Floridian fashion,
the subconscious in inside out is represented by a dark cave filled with Riley's
deep repressed fears.
The stairs to the basement.
But treating underground spaces as only places of doom and despair.
What's seldom short in many films, the underground does the exact opposite.
It lets characters chillax.
Yeah. My basement, the chill zone is where we kill lacks,
like relaxing chill all at once.
In real life. Basements give people a space to unwind and hang out,
save from the problems of the world above ground.
And in attempt to protect their masculinity.
Men have invented their own underground space to shield them from the
above-ground pains of dating and marriage. This.
Is the man cave. No women allowed in here.
In more dramatic films, basements protect people from harm.
They can temporarily keep a family safe for monsters,
or they can let you make math without the cops finding out.
I'd be willing to bet that movies actually more often portrayed basements as a
place of protection than a place of danger.
Whether an underground layer protects your secret identity or an underground
civilization protects you from a robot invasion.
The underground creates a space that hides characters from both literal and
metaphorical danger at the end of super bad,
Seth and Evan retreat to Evan's basement to have a sleepover.
And they confess how much they cherish each other. In this scene,
the underground basement acts as a place where they can both be vulnerable and
no longer have to act cool like they do in the rest of the film,
the setting calls back to their lifelong childhood friendship,
and it's a comfortable space.
They will have to let go of when they go to different colleges for Seth and
Evan, the childhood basement represents a time they enjoy together,
but also a time they have to move on from, as they grow up.
Many films treat underground spaces as comfortable,
but sometimes they can become too comfortable.
A character stuck in a basement can symbolize someone unable to handle the real
world.
Meeting with dry bird left bed tasting house,
the flubby failures when bringing his basement.
The classic example of the cushy underground is the loser who still lives in his
mom's basement.
Although these days that feels more like a smart financial decision than the
sign of a loser. But to keep the story moving and narrative films,
almost always challenged that initial safety of the underground,
or they make the safe underground, create a new problem.
A bunker may protect characters from the dangers of the outside world,
but they don't protect them from the people they're now stuck with the
claustrophobia of underground spaces.
Often forces people into conflict with one another. In war of the worlds reign,
his daughter finds refuge from alien invaders by hiding out in a man's basement.
But when the aliens break in, they are at odds with how to deal with them.
Ray wants to keep quiet, but the man wants to fight back.
I think Ray quickly learns that the biggest threat to his daughter's safety
isn't the aliens they're hiding from it's their supposed savior.
They're stuck with underground.
Another film that plays with the uncertain safety of underground spaces is 10
Cloverfield lane,
which constantly makes the viewer question whether or not the bunker is a
shelter from a radioactive atmosphere, or if it's actually a prison cell,
Michelle spends the movie plotting away out then questioning.
If she even wants to get out this claustrophobic underground showcases the
tactics of relationships. It might suck in the bunker,
but outside it's even worse.
After I saved you and kept you safe. This is how you repay me.
An underground space may protect someone from above-ground catastrophes,
but it leaves them much more vulnerable to interpersonal conflict with the
people they're stuck with a perfect example of this underground dynamic is
Walton Jesse working in the meth super lab in breaking bad throughout the early
seasons. The two characters have lots of problems to deal with.
They have to keep their meth making lives,
a secret avoid detection from the cops.
And they struggle with the various challenges of cooking meth in an RV.
But once they move their work into the underground super lab,
many of those problems go away.
The super lab works well and Gus helps protect them from the police at the
beginning, Walton, Jesse treat the job like a typical nine to five.
This underground space protects them from the outside world,
but it also magnifies the existing social problems between the two characters
compare a conflict between Walt and Jesse in the RV to a conflict between them
in the super lab. In an early episode,
the RV runs out of battery in the middle of the boonies.
They bicker at each other throughout the episode,
but they mainly try to work together to keep themselves from dying of thirst.
In the fly episode, Walt obsesses,
over killing a fly that has contaminated the super lab.
And throughout the episode, Jesse sees it as a waste of time.
Both situations involve a conflict that they must solve,
but the situation feels completely different in the RV.
It's a matter of life or death.
And while they may not approach the problem in the same way,
they both understand what's at stake. But in the fly episode,
the conflict is much less about the fly itself than it is about the conflict
between Jesse and Walt compared to the RV situation.
The threat feels in consequential.
The biggest conflict comes not from an outside force, but from within
the two can't even agree on whether there's a problem and to all the setbacks
come from the two undermining each other, like when Jesse cuts off the power,
there are many possible interpretations of what the fly symbolizes in this
episode.
But what's clear is that the setting creates a high pressure claustrophobic
environment that forces us to focus on the relationship between Walt and Jesse
because of the isolated space of the underground super lap.
The two have the most revealing personal dialogue in the entire series
throughout breaking bad.
Some of the most important and revealing moments occur in the underground.
And the show uses the underground in a variety of ways like many films.
The show uses the underground to keep things safe.
The super lab protects Walt and Jesse from the DEA,
but there's also Walt hiding his money in his crawlspace.
And Jesse storing the meth setup in his basement to avoid detection.
But there are more cultural functions of the underground that you may not have
considered underground spaces. Don't just protect what is precious.
They also dispose of what is harmful for many crime shows.
The underground is the perfect way to dispose of a body in breaking bad.
Walt and Jesse bring crazy eight to the basement to dispose of him.
While Walt talks with him,
the underground sang reminds us that crazy eights life is on the line.
The underground can also allow characters to yield valuable resources.
You can literally yield from the earth by mining for minerals,
or you can even find kid and treasure,
but there are also less literal ways to yield value in the underground.
In breaking bad.
Gus uses the underground super lab to extract math made by Walt, Jesse.
But when people are involved, extraction almost always means exploitation.
In one episode,
Jesse realizes just how valuable their work in the super lab has been for Gus.
All right, 96,000,096,
two hour three, that is messed up y'all.
While waltz scolds him for being ungrateful.
Jessie points out that the whole deal is unfair.
Do you live in one where the dudes are actually doing all the
work and getting fisted?
He says this,
the camera cuts to a new extreme high angle shot looking down at Jesse as he
rails against the exploitation of his labor.
It's no coincidence that Jesse gets framed from such a powerless angle.
When he's feeling ripped off filmmakers often use perspective to emphasize
control a high angle shot makes the character look small and helpless while they
low angle shot. It makes them look powerful.
Add in the fact that Jesse is underground and it becomes clear that the below
ground super lab emphasizes Jessie and waltz powerlessness like the bunker in 10
Cloverfield lane. The lab is both a refuge and a prison,
their boss surveils them constantly. They work under threat of bodily harm.
And at the end of the day,
they make a small fraction of what Gus makes the episode box cutter uses the
spacial hierarchy to visually demonstrate Gus as power overwhelmed Jesse,
after re-establishing his authority by killing his loyal henchman,
he leaves the lab.
The scene is intentionally shot to emphasize the spatial relationship between
Gus and his employees. He looks down on them and they look back up at him,
defeated and traumatized.
Get back to work.
Your ground is a symbol of Walt and Jesse status as part of an underclass that
serves at the whims of wealthy upper management.
After all breaking bad is a show about class anxiety.
Walt's financial struggles are core to the show and Jessie struggles with this
inability to be a productive member of society.
It's no surprise then that the show uses the underground so extensively because
it serves as a clear illustration of a hierarchical and exploitated world that
forces them to sell their souls to survive and breaking bad.
Isn't the only example of a story that uses the undergrounds to explore class
dining.
Hammocks.
The film parasites starts with a pedestal shot,
moving downward to reveal a semi underground apartment.
The pedestal shot gives subtle cues to the viewer by moving the camera up or
down, it indicates whether a character is.
Or powerless. Yes, that should do it.
In the case of parasite,
the shot reinforces that this family is part of the powerless underclass.
There are semi underground departments symbolizes their low status in the
socioeconomic hierarchy.
The beginning of the film revolves around the family trying to literally rise
above their station. Even in the very first scene,
they're trying to get reliable wifi by holding their phones up to the ceiling.
Symbolically showing that their success lies upward.
When the son gets an opportunity to tutor for a much wealthier family,
he makes the track to their house and in each shot, he moves upward.
Along with a pedestal shot.
The film also uses high angle and low angle shots throughout this early sequence
to show power. In the beginning, the camera looks down on the poor family,
but as they infiltrate the rich home, they gained control of the frame at times,
towering over the rich family,
both the camera and the above ground setting emphasize the changing hierarchy
between the two families,
but all of that ends with the discovery of a new underground space.
The nuclear bunker,
This underground space completely reverses the trajectory of the story.
In the beginning of the film, the family becomes successful by moving upward,
but in a cruel twist of fate, their upward plan starts to unravel.
Once they expose themselves by literally falling downward
again,
underground space represents the powerless and the Kim family instantly lose
their control. The nuclear bunker in parasite has many symbolic meanings.
It does protect what is valuable. That's what nuclear bunkers were made for.
They protect people from a potential nuclear attack in the film.
The bunker keeps a man saved from the loan sharks, trying to catch it,
but that protection comes at a price and it eventually drives its inhabitants
matte and 12,
a bunker doesn't yield value in a literal way like bury treasure or crystal
meth. It does heal the big twist in the story itself.
Parasite follows the tradition of countless films that use an underground space
as the climactic moment or as a major plot twist.
There are lots of films with surprise underground spaces that I won't talk about
to avoid spoiling them, which goes to show just how important those spaces are.
For many stories.
What makes parasites such an incredible example of the underground is in how
many ways it uses it to tell its story parasite uses the underground,
not only to emphasize hierarchy and exploitation,
but to show how the stench of the underground never really leaves people who
managed to climb their way up.
You can see all these ideas of the underground and the very last shot of the
film after the sun vows to get rich and save his father from the bunker,
we get the same pedestal shot from the beginning,
no matter how hard he tries or how much he plans,
he remains trapped underground, the underground.
Isn't just a physical space in this film.
It's a social boundary policed by the norms and manners of an upper-class
society with no interest in admitting anyone new in parasite,
there is no meritocracy. The hatch of the underground is locked and sealed
Basements. Aren't just scary because they're cold and dark.
They're scary because of their power. As a storytelling device in film and TV,
the underground represents a new unexplored space that may be a source of
safety, danger, or reward.
This unknown creates dramatic tension because it's so unknown.
When we see a basement we're introduced to a completely new space and we have no
idea what's going to be down there waiting for us in a way,
almost every underground space in film and TV yields, something valuable.
They yield the most valuable part of the story.
So the next time you see a basement in a film,
don't forget to consider how deep it really goes.
Like most. Now you see it videos.
This one only contains a fraction of all the thoughts and ideas we had around
this topic,
but we want to let you in on the deeper conversations we had about the
undergrounds breaking bad and parasite,
we do that and more in our latest episode of the now you hear in podcast,
the now you hear it. Podcast goes in-depth on each month's topic,
expands our thoughts and discusses related topics that didn't make it into the
video. You can get exclusive access to our past two episodes.
Plus our brand new episode on the underground,
by going to patrion.com/now you see it and becoming a $5 tier member.
And if you want to check out our first episode for free,
the link is in the description, getting access to now,
you hear it is the perfect way to support the channel while also getting
exclusive long form content. So hit the subscribe button, head to our Patrion,
and thanks for watching.